hello everyone this is the 1994 world
with Championship semi-final match
between Ilyas Mirren and respond at an
island and I don't only needs the draw
in this game to win the match
so explain with black pieces and he has
five minutes on the clock and Ilyas
Marin has six minutes on the clock and
whoever wins the match is facing garry
kasparov in the finals so it was it's
somewhat of a theoretical game but also
on ensures extreme fighting spirit and
also why they call him the lightning kid
I do hope you enjoyed this game we have
efore by smearin p5 Knight to f3 Knight
to f6 is the petrel defense or the
Russian opening if you will
d4 I haven't played nine chapters on e4
and we had a nice captures on e5 and
this is a fairly rare line and it's
exactly in this position did Anand was
thinking for one minute and 43 seconds
and it was quite a vivid experience to
tellus and to Maurice Ashley at the
young Maurice Ashley for one minute and
43 seconds about why Anand isn't making
a move and okay after this time on and
plays d6 and he continues the game
purely theoretically we have Knight f3
d5 Bishop to d3 Knight to c6 castles 57
c4 not to be for attacking the bishop so
Bishop e2 Bishop to e6 and Knight to c3
castles Bishop to e3 Bishop the f5 rook
to see one and non-employees D captures
on c4 we have Bishop captures on c4 n r
c6 restricting this restricting this
knight on c3 and also preparing an
outpost for his own knight on d5 smearin
goes 95 and iron place tonight chapters
on c3 we have B factors on c3 and i-95
and the same place Queen to b3 attacking
this pawn and b7 and also well kind of
adding pressure to this d5 square and
it's exactly because of our next move
that I think Anand was actually trying
to remember this line when he was
singing for Rose one minutes and 43
seconds because I don't plays f6 here
and this is okay he
taking the night out of e5 but do you
really want to open your Kings to this I
mean then and also allowing this Queen
casters mb7 but I guess he assessed the
position correctly because smearing
immediately plays the plays Queen
Catherine b7 as Marian thought that
after F captors on e5 he will captured
upon and c6 and this night will fall but
this is what actually happens we have s
casters on e5 Queen Catherine c6 and a
threatening to capture the night but
smear and miss this move Bishop to e4
and now the night is defended and he
spent some time here and f3 here isn't
working just to keep the Bishop from
from e4 because if f3 then Aaron has
this very nice King 288 unpinning and
now of course if you capture the bishop
Aaron captures the bishop on e3 so first
you'd have to play Bishop to f2 and now
honored has a way out of this rook to f6
would an attack on the Queen and after
Queen to a4 nice to b6 would another
attack on the Queen as for Queen b3 now
Knight captures on c4 and another nice
would be threatening this Knight B to
with an attack and the king and the rook
so Queens after c4 and I simply Bishop
to d5 and black is perfectly fine here
of a piece and this is winning for black
so after Bishop to e4 it was quite a
surprise for smearin and he continued
with the D captors on e5 and okay he's
down a piece but he is up three pawns
this D captures only five wins the third
point on plays King to h8 unpinning and
we have Bishop to d4 and like I said
white like on this down a piece but he
has this very nice - Bishop sighing the
black King there and he's up three
points so it's not a bad position but
it's from this position on that and
really destroys destroys the position
and he plays he plays almost instant
moves he plays rook c8 with an attack on
the Queen we have Queen to a6 and now
nice to f4 and disregards that this a7
poem is about to fall and attacks this G
- bond we have f3 and again this is all
played instantly by Anand we have worked
the c6 with an attack on the Queen Queen
to a4 and our rook captures
see for an exchange sacrifice we have
Queen captures on c4 and now Anna plays
Bishop to d3 with an attack on the Queen
and on the rock here we have Queen to c6
and now not capturing the rook but Allen
plays rook to e to check forking both
rooks and the bishop here we have King
to h1 and now on our captures the bishop
wants to exchange as many pieces as you
can as his upper piece and well he will
win another point here we have a seek
after 74 as the knight was attacking the
Queen and only now Bishop captures an f1
we have real captures on f1 and helping
theatres on d4 and now on and managed to
exchange everything he's up a piece and
white doesn't have three points now he
has he's up two points and Anand is
threatening to capture on e5 so he plays
to f4 and he blunders here because now
Ana's has this Queen captures an e5 idea
as the Queen cannot be captured because
rook F one who would be checkmate so we
have G 3 and on plays Queen c5 and okay
I mean he's protecting his a 7-point
threatening to exchange wins this is
completely winning for black but like I
said the winner of this semi-final match
a semi-final of the World Championship
faces Garry Kasparov in the final so he
decided to play a couple of more moves
would help Quinte e4 with an attack on
the bishop there a bishop to f6
kingi two throughout the c8 and are
threatening to exchange Queens
we have rook F 2 and our queen to c6
now forcing the exchange of Queen's
Queen captures were captures and there
is nothing for whites to try here except
maybe you know okay she could maybe
stalemate him but a draw still is enough
run to win the match we have G for h6
King f3 Rob's III King G for King 287
rook to e2 rope c4 can get 5 rook c5
King e6 group C for ruckus - in g 6h 3
roots III rook H to rook F 3 F 525 a 4
th for King d5 and now of course not
capturing on h3 but first locate 3 of
course
can be Kim c6 rock casters on a 14 B 7
now a 5k b6
rocketry can be 5 and our objectors on
h3 and in this position million resigns
the game as after drop moved King goes
in to gobble up all of these pawns so
yeah I'm definitely a beautiful
beautiful game and quiet quite a quite a
show by by the future world champion
which planet and Island as he did play a
magnificent game here and I do also have
one other theory I one of the theory of
mine went away on and spent the one
minute and 43 seconds in that move was
after he after his own eyes captures on
e-file maybe he knew this line so well
that he was just you know doing nothing
for one minute and 43 seconds just just
you know to mess mess with girls here
and said you know psych him out so maybe
maybe even that's possible to throw him
off his game
but I but probably it was something
about trying to remember that f6 line
but who knows maybe some of you know
this better and maybe maybe you have a
better theory on this which I was a lot
to hear in the comments and say that it
hope you enjoyed this beautiful game as
usual you can check two of my previous
videos here and yeah I'll see you soon